[Music]
look out JLo Ben Affleck is coming for
your mic I think is very exciting
Jennifer Lopez and her hubby kicked off
the holidays on Saturday with a bash at
their Hollywood home and lucky for us
partygoers shared snaps from inside the
Soiree giving us an inside look which
included festive twinkly lights Endless
Pizza and outdoor bar a giant
gingerbread house and a hot cocoa
station it was just perfect but it
wouldn't be a JLo party without a little
music that's what I plan to give them a
great show a great night Jen put her
vocal chops on full display at the piano
Where You Are
You Can Count On Me
but she wasn't the only one
yeah that's Ben at the mic singing
alongside his wife for A Soulful
rendition of John Legend's by Christmas
Eve
[Music]
pretty good right I've never seen
anything like it well JLo seemed to
think so too throwing her arms around
her man and planting a big old smooch on
his cheek
[Applause]
of course this has been a first
Christmas as husband and wife and a
source previously told E.T that the
lovebirds are having so much fun leading
up to the big day adding that it's a
really exciting time for them as a
couple what can I tell you we're just
having a good time quote Jen's favorite
holiday is Christmas so she always goes
all out our source adds that Ben and Jen
picked out and decorated a huge tree
with the help of their children Ben
shares three kiddos with his ex Jennifer
Garner 17 year old Violet 13 year old
Seraphina and 10 year old Samuel as for
Jen she's mom to 14 year old twins Max
and Emmy their dad is ex Marc Anthony I
find myself incredibly blessed now ET
Source says the couple is planning to
spend the holidays together with the
kids and Jen's family adding that Jen
her mom and sister are all amazing Cooks
so you know there's gonna be some
amazing food and when it comes to
presents under the Christmas tree our
source says Jen plans to spoil Ben
I'm working on it now and Ben he has
some surprises up his sleeve too quote
Ben is planning on giving Jen a couple
of things that are special and
sentimental that have taken him a long
time to find of course Ben and Jen tied
the knot this summer nearly two decades
after calling off their first engagement
in 2004. you look gorgeous God bless you
somebody's getting married and now one
thing's for sure these two are living
out there happily ever after
[Applause]
[Music]